je voudrais ariane moffatt et ses 18
musiciens mettent le paquet pour
l'ouverture des 31e franco un peu
mégalomaniaque un peu plus grande que
nature le besoin de jouer d'avoir des
arrangements très dense d'amener cette
touche qui feront de la soul jazz d'y
aller crémone en mars
[Musique]
parmi les autres grands événements à
l'extérieur il y as saffiano l'un deux
frères et émilie bilodeau
[Musique]
et le rappeur en pleine ascension fu chi
qui à 22 ans a convaincu l'organisation
de lui céder la grande scène sa tantine
me donner la grosse npd huawei relaxe
relaxe finalement je les ai eus fait que
je suis vraiment content by un petit
stress mais beaucoup plus d'excitation
qu'autre chose
il ya aussi des grands retours comme le
groupe français les [ __ ] vertes
marc déry daniel boucher et pendant rech
on fait jamais beaucoup de conneries
pendant les francos mais on s'est dit
que tant qu'à faire il fallait que ce
soit monsieur d'arâches les hôtesses
d'hilaire et le collectif salle barbe
composé notamment de jean françois breau
veulent faire la fête à l'acadienne on
sort les violons la planche à laver les
guitares électriques mais les gens
connaissent ou pas les chansons au bout
de deux refrains sont embarqués
complètement de sa danse ont fait long
feu vraiment de la musique pour les
pieds il car au rayon des découvertes
d'ici les divertissant le jeans bleu
le groupe de l'élevage les méchants et
le sympathique joêl de sa radio four
dans ce cadre les nouvelles sensations
européenne faux et vendredi sur mer et
elle essaie mois débarqué avec leur
musique pop teintée d'électro
[Musique]
mario pelchat reprend le répertoire de
charles aznavour et pierre lapointe lui
offre la science du coeur avec
l'orchestré métropolitain
c'est un des plus beaux projet musical
que j'ai fait de ma vie
la version symphonique c'est une version
amplifiée de l'album et pour boucler
l'événement coriace fera lever les
foules
sous les étoiles
ici julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
ligne anti n'est qu'en signant tous les
6 mois d'abord mis ma soeur fortement au
fleuret j'ai fait mais j'ai tout fait
exploser par là